and finally new rule my dashboard
doesn't need any more indicators is your
seatbelt on are your tires inflated is
your oil changed jeez if I wanted to be
nagged as much I get married and right
now in Washington Democrats have
introduced federal legislation requiring
car manufacturers to install a motion
sensor that would remind drivers that
they left their kid in the back seat
really it's called the hot cars act
because turn around [ __ ] was too
on-the-nose but if someone's too high to
remember their kid you think they're
gonna see a little yellow light there
were over 17 million new cars sold in
America last year are we really going to
require them all to install sensors the
cost of which will be passed on to the
consumer to prevent something less
likely than being struck by lightning
and should reminding you not to forget
your baby really be Toyota's problem
[Applause]
where does this stop chunks of toilet
ice yes I said it
toilet ice fall out of the sky from
airplanes all the time that's gonna kill
some unlucky [ __ ] someday
why not the piss ice act requiring all
vehicle roofs to be reinforced to
withstand a urine iceberg drop from
30,000 feet here in California we make
just about every business Under the Sun
put up this sign that says warning
detectable amounts of chemicals known to
cause cancer may be found around this
facility no [ __ ] we live in LA it's
called air
Honolulu recently banned looking at your
phone while crossing the street but wait
what if I'm getting an important message
like that I've left my baby in a hot car
and here's where someone always says but
if it saves one life
oh [ __ ] you know what you could put kids
in bubble wrap all day and it would save
some but would it be worth it we're
never going to get this down to zero
until we get rid of kids all together
[Applause]
and I keep signing the petition but it
never happens until then all this will
accomplish is to feed into the
Republican message the Democrats don't
want to help people they just want to
micromanage their lives it makes people
hate us it makes me hate us and it
prompts kickback that's how you get an
environmental protected protection
agency headed by a man who cares nothing
about environmental protection and I
hate to tell you but we are all in an
overheating vehicle it's called Earth
that's why that's why I say to Democrats
either go big or go home
no one is for leaving babies in hot cars
it's just that common sense tells most
people this is an issue of personal
responsibility especially when the
liberal solution to your human frailty
is me paying more for [ __ ] that can
break in my car thanks government we'll
get to gun control later and that's the
point we do need regulation oh yes for
big things real things like guns and
carbon emissions and banks but when
Democrats get to regulating everything
regulation itself gets a bad name and I
don't want to I don't want to let the
right-wing own freedom people want to
drain the swamp not ban big gulps yes I
understand you have a thousand good idea
for how I should live my life check my
privilege and sort my recycling and
we'll get to that but first we need to
get some Democrats elected and that's
hard when the movement to childproof the
world has made Republicans the party of
freedom and Democrats the party of
poopers